[Music]  to the outside world the amish seem kind  loving generous but the odds of an amish  woman getting raped by a guy within  their own community it's one out of  every six on a good day  first perpetrator was my biological  father  i was five  the amish carved out a different way of  existing the church wields power and  control under the church the wives only  have as much voice as their husbands  allow they bust in four across loads of  amish people not a single one of them  was very important for me amish  communities view going to the police as  a greater sin than the rape itself it's  a predator's paradise  it takes a courageous person to go  against that community sometimes we have  to face our biggest fear  he wants two years work release no  incarceration he's a pedophile we're the  crack in the damn but when that blood  comes  justice has to follow  [Music]  you